The general Hogan experience. I went down a pathway with Queens gambit,
where I was like, is this a true story? Because if this is true,
that there was this beautiful young flawed woman.
That's very interesting to me. It's not a true story.
I there's a lot of people on the internet who think that it is a true story.
Uh it's based off a book, but just sales are through the roof.
You couldn't get a chess board when that thing came out. Really? Yeah.
Isn't that hilarious? Like, like chess sales were going crazy,
which Jess is a beautiful sport and um,
much like long form conversation we have here long form game. Yeah. I mean,
months you could really play. They, they, they get into speed chess in that, uh,
in that show, but you can play chess forever, man. Yeah.
I'm scared of chess. I'm terrible at chess.
And I don't want to get good at it because, uh,
I think it's something that I would get absorbed with.
I remember there was a time where Howard stern got obsessed with chess and he
was taking chess lessons when he was talking about, on the show. Yeah. Yeah.
And I, I remember thinking, Oh, he's an obsessive, like heel heel,
and then eventually bailed and stuff stopped doing it. But, um,
I've had problems with video games. I've had problems with pool.
I used to play pool competitively and I get,
I get real obsessed with games and chess seems to be like the most
intensive, all intellectual games.
Trigger the out of your intellectual. What,
what kind of billiards would we play? Nine ball. Yeah.
Nine ball, 10 ball, straight pool. I played a lot of all those games,
but I played a lot of pool a lot. I played a lot of tournaments. Yeah.
To the point where, um, I have, I have a table in my old studio.
I have a table at home. Um, I collect pool cues. I have a bunch of pool cues.
These are cool. Oh yeah.
Actually when they unscrew and you take you out to the briefcase and you know,
a dollar money color, money's just in the case in here, dude,
that's let, it's such a good movie.
My brother Todd got obsessed with pool and we had a pool table in our basement,
but it was like classic Midwest basement in that it couldn't,
it wasn't fully unobstructed. So we had this,
we had this like weight bearing pole right here.
If you ever had to go like in the, in the, uh, the middle, you know,
you had to do all this creative, short stick. We saw one down,
but Todd got really into poor.
My dad took us to the nine ball championships one year down in like West
Virginia. And we're like, you know, these guys are like excellent at pool.
I mean, they'll run racks after racks. And it was like wild,
how the brain is not how my brain works, but my brother's brain,
what we call like one ball there, two ball there is going to move it off here.
And that's like, geometry, chess. It's all like that. Yeah.
It is. And it's also finesse and touch and feel. Yeah.
And it sounds, yeah. It's also a sport that thrives on drugs.
Really like an Adderall type.
Situation because they would gamble and they would play for hours, 15,
16 hours.
The thing about pool was that they would play until someone quit.
And so.
Guys like the gentlemen, you would never.
Quit on somebody when you were ahead. So like, if you, if you quit on someone,
when you're ahead, people would be mad at you.
And they didn't like if you played like for two hours and you won like a
thousand dollars in New Zealand, uh, we'll play again tomorrow. They'd be like,
you stay. And people get mad at you. They would really get upset.
And you would have a hard time getting a game because you'd be a guy.
Wipe out your opponent until they say, I can't do this anymore.
It's like to the death, to the death.
Yeah. It's like amongst top players in less,
there was an agreement like you could make an agreement and you can make an
agreement. We will play two sets. I'll play you two sets,
race to 20 for X amount of dollars per set.
But we're going to make an agreement right now. Two sets, right?
That's rare though.
Most of the time they would post up and they would play until guys went broke,
like the hustler, the hustler with Jackie Gleason and Paul Newman.
That was the theme of the movie is that Paul Newman's winning for like 15,
16 hours.
And then Jackie Gleason has character and Paul Newman is self destructive.
And eventually Jackie Gleason overcomes him.
Ever seen the hustler. But obviously that great is helped.
Paul Newman get cast in color money. Oh, that was like short.
That was the color of, yeah, that's what I went through.
The color of money was the sequel. Okay. I didn't realize that.
Yeah. They were both written by, I think Walter Tevis is the guy who wrote it,
but I've read the books too. They're pretty similar. Um, the, the,
the character in the second movie is different. Like,
there's a lot of things in the color of money.
They're different than made for Tom cruise. And, but in the hustler,
Paul Newman, uh, retires, because like, he's,
he makes a deal with this mob guy. And at the end of it, he quits playing.
And so he's, he's retired from pool.
And then he meets Tom cruise many decades later.
So the hustler is takes the hostel takes place. I think in,
I want to say 63, somewhere around then. That's when that movie came out.
And so the color money is like 1984 color, muddy,
gray that, that made pool go through the roof.
People started playing pool crazy. And people pool people, the pool world,
I've always said they need a movie,
like the color of money and the pool hall junkies. Some people liked,
but it never really had the same impact. It wasn't that good. It was okay.
Like some people liked it, but they couldn't really play. Right.
If a person who plays pool, like I watched it,
it would be very frustrating for me. Cause like,
if you were watching someone play tennis.
It's it infuriates me any commercial with tennis,
they're holding the racket wrong. It's like,
just get anyone that plays tennis to quickly advise you on the right grip.
And now I'm like, but all I can focus on is that,
and I believe color money. I,
I remember reading about it that they like lock Tom cruise in a room for three
months and taught them how to shoot.
And the crews worked with Mike seagull and Mike Siegel is one of the greatest
pool players that's ever lived. Multiple time world champion,
like literally one of the all-time greats.
I've had the opportunity to play Mike Siegel. I played him. I hung out with him.
He's a great guy. Um, and he was also, left-handed just like Tom.
And he taught Tom cruise and Tom cruise looks like a guy who can play a little
Paul Newman in the hustler does not really look like a guy can play.
He does a lot of goofy. Right. But Jackie Gleason could play.
Jackie Gleason literally plays like a professional.
You watch Jackie Gleason in the hustler.
Like he spent a lot of time playing pool when he was a kid like, look,
Jackie Gleason was a guy who drank and smoked and hung out in pool halls.
He was a man's man. He was a, he was a, you know,
a wild dude and he could play like really play.
How did you get introduced to pool? I hurt my ACL.
I tore my ACL ligament. I couldn't work out for awhile. And, uh,
when I couldn't work out, me and my friend, John star, he was a comic as well.
We started going to this pool hall in white Plains, New York. And, uh,
I just stumbled upon one of the great pool halls in that area.
It's one of the reasons why I moved to new Rochelle,
because I could be close to white Plains because I was addicted to this pool.
We'll get addicted to pool sound. My brother was right.
What does it say? Yeah. The video game doom got its name from the film. Yeah.
The video game doom got its name from Tom cruise opening up that, uh,
because they want to know that. Yeah.
Because when he opened up the case and he goes, what's in the case, he goes,
get here.
Doom. I remember that with his dumb accent. Yes, he was.
He was excellent in that film. That's what Johnny.
Yeah. That's what they wanted to, uh,
John Carmack wanted to say to the video game world, when they,
when they released doom, what's in their doom. Is it like,
because this game is so crazy in comparison to everything else. Yeah.
So that's where it came up with. We came up with the name.
Yeah. It's something like the, the,
I forget the character's name and queen Queen's gambit,
but when she kind of lays in bed, it looks up and watches the world.
You kind of see like pool players look at the, at the, um,
table that way to debt, to debt. This goes here to Digita and.
There's with pool there's execution, right?
The differences you could miss a shot where you're in perfect position.
Whereas the chess, you just move the thing,
you don't have to think about your physical hand-eye coordination and skill.
So nerves don't play a factor as much in terms of your ability to move your
body. So with pool,
the thing that excited me about it was it was about controlling yourself
under pressure.
And you're literally applying a certain amount of pressure to a ball.
And you want to control the revolutions that the ball makes over a
long period. So it's all touch and feel. And the more you play,
the more and you in what they call dead punch or dead stroke,
where you understand exactly how much impact and exactly
how hard to touch that cue. Exactly how much,
how much impact it has on the ball to just perfectly place that ball in position
for the next shot.
It is a, it's a great game.
My brother had a book called how to hustle your friends at Poole.
And he used to read it and, uh,
we'd have friends come over and they would always get mad that he was reading
the book. But, but he loved it. It's a great gambling sport. Yeah. It's cool.
It's a game where people get mad. If you pretend you're not good. Right.
And it turns out you are good. And that's what the hustle is. Yeah. Right.
But what's interesting about it is it's also a game where people lie about how
good they are. Like men always want to pretend. They're really good at pool.
It's a weird thing. Like if guys don't know you play, like,
I play pretty good. Like I'm a B player, which means like,
I'm not a pro,
but if I practice for six months and really dedicated myself to be excellent,
I can run racks. I've, I've run out three, four racks in a row.
I can play a little. Yeah. And if I played a lot, I could, I could,
I could play on a very high level,
but most people can't like I played for years, eight hours a day.
I played every day. I always played,
I took a cue on the road with me everywhere. I went, when I,
when I would go on the road and do do gigs, I find pool halls.
And I play pool all night long. That's what I always did. Most men lie.
Like they tell you, like you say, do you play pool? Oh yeah. Are you good? Yeah.
I'm pretty good. Like, are you really like, how good are you? I'm good.
I always beat my friends. Pretty good. You're like, do, are you really good?
Like if you ever played in tournaments,
the lie and then you play them and they suck.
Golf is like this, what do you shoot a about a hundred.
You go out there and you're like, you lie.
Or you cheat everybody cheats a golf.
Everybody gets so surprised when they asked me if I'm good at golf. And I say,
Oh, I'm okay. And they say, what do you shoot? And I say, one 10. They got no,
there's no chance I get out there.
And you really count my strokes in the time that I moved the ball.
And the time that it like followed the rules shot at one 10. But everybody.
Is that a good number? No. No. What, what, what's a good number.
Yeah. Par is 72, but I guarantee you,
he's going to say he shoots in the nineties and when we go out there and we
actually play, he's going to shoot like 125, like a typical
[inaudible] is probably a good number. Yeah. Number I could get there, but,
but you would need a lot of time in some time and, and you don't cheat,
but everybody, life is fun. It's true. People lie about,
but we'll do it the worst.
If you're a single guy trying to like pick up girls and you got to play pool
with them and they're like garbage, they beat you for girl beats your pool.
Good luck, good luck. They don't want to you. If they can beat you a pool.
Everyone knows that catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free.
Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.